bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors on vient de l'apprendre
le procès de matteo salvini est reporté
au 20 novembre la justice souhaite
d'abord entendre le premier ministre et
giuseppe comptait avant de se prononcer
sur l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur est
ce que ce report change quoi que ce soit
pour matteo salvini sans doute ça donne
un signal très fort de du fait que son
rang sa ligne de défense est fondée
alors que l'accusation se base sur des
bases plutôt faible son avocat a
expliqué tout à l'heure dans une
conférence de presse qui a été diffusé
sur la page facebook de matteo salvini
elle a expliqué que en fait déjà il y à
une requête de non lieu qui a été
présentée parce que d'une part le
tribunal de catane l'année passée avait
déjà décidé la l'archi via sion
d'achille et le la plainte parce qu'elle
n'était pas suffisamment fondées et de
l'autre côté parce que par exemple cette
nouvelle plante qui étaient présentés
selon des règles qui sont un peu
compliquées à synthétiser en ce moment
mais qui a été représentée devant le
tribunal des ministres italien déjà part
d'un erreur de traduction parce que
selon les accusations
matteo salvini aurait dû faire débarquer
faire descendre du navire
immédiatement les migrants selon en
appliquant des règles européennes
aof ses règles européennes ne parlent
pas d'immédiateté mais parle de voir que
de devoir qu'il y aller les basques de
s'assurer qu'il ya les conditions pour
pouvoir bien accueilli ces personnes
donc matin à mini à travers son avocat
est en train de essayer de montrer que
d'une part il y avait une décision
politique en amont qui faisait
d'ailleurs partie aussi du contrat de
gouvernement
signé par toutes les forces qui
composaient le gouvernement comptait lui
mais roy et de l'autre côté que en fait
il n'était pas obligé par les mêmes
règles européennes qui est qu'on devrait
s'appliquer aussi et dans les errements
de sept autres pays de faire débarquer
de faire descendre tout de suite les
migrants alors oui on va rappeler les
faits salvini est accusé d'abus de
pouvoir et à séquestration personnes les
faits reprochés je le rappelle remonte à
l'été 2010 9 lorsqu'il a bloqué le
débarquement de 115 116 migrants
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur se dit
aujourd'hui serein il qualifie ces
accusations d'inapproprié il estime
avoir en fait appliquer la politique qui
l'a fait élire
qu'est-ce qui ne vise que matteo salvini
précisément à ce qu'il doive s'inquiéter
de l'issue de ce procès doit s'inquiéter
si on continuera à avoir une injustice
très politisée et qui d'ailleurs est une
mm en discussion la séparation de
pouvoirs qui existe aussi en italie et
qui comme l'expliqué très bien votre
reportage risque de créer des conflits
institutionnel entre les différents
pouvoirs de la république italienne
il ne risque pas en revanche de perdre
le soutien et de tout le centre audois
qui s'est présenté compact derrière lui
à catane séjour parce que il ya eu
plusieurs manifestations en soutien et
contre matteo salvini et surtout ne
risque pas de perdre le soutien des
électeurs parce que on a vu que aussi
dans les dernières élections régionales
du vent et 21 septembre
il n'a pas le centre droit n'a pas
réussi à importer des victoires dans
deux régions historiquement rouge donc
aux gouvernés par la gauche mais quand
même il a gagné une région de plus et
maintenant quinze régions sur 20 sont
gouvernées par le centre droit est donc
aussi par le parti de matteo salvini
en tout cas il faut toujours se rappeler
que matteo salvini à appliquer des
décisions justement prises par le
gouvernement
parce qu'en plus en italie le
gouvernement et les fonctions selon à la
règle et de la collégialité
le conseil des ministres on l'appelle
justement et en plus il était en train
de faire le travail d'un ministre de
l'intérieur donc imaginez vous aussi
monsieur dorman ans devait répondre
devant un tribunal pour avoir exercé son
pouvoir pour que ministre juste cette
précision matteo salvini ils encourent
15 ans de prison c'est ce n'est pas rien
mais comment est perçue justement ce
procès par l'opinion publique italienne
l'opinion publique est très polarisée il
y à une partie qui soutient les partis
actuellement au gouvernement c'est à
dire le centre gauche et le mouvement 5
étoiles qui
pense que il faut effectivement mené
jusqu'à la prison matteo salvini l'autre
côté de la deûle autre côté on a des
électeurs qui sont plus proches du
centre droit non seulement de la ligue
de matteo salvini et qui justement au
delà du cas les matins salvini rappelle
qu' il s'agit d'un potentiel conflit
constitutionnelles institutionnelles et
qui donc pourra aussi s'est représenté
pour d'autres ministres pour d'autres
gouvernements
matteo ghisalberti ce sera le mot de la
fin je rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur
en chef de putsch médias